one or two words before we start today
so I hope you all enjoyed supremacy
Monday yesterday and we complement it
today with experimental Tuesday if you
get too overloaded with that we return
to the safety of Theory Wednesday
tomorrow we have four great speakers
tonight and but I will turn it over for
the moderation of the session to Ignacio
Ciroc well include one in California I'm
here in European Munich and welcome
everybody to this second session and so
we have the luck to have with us some of
the leading experimentalist and quantum
computing and the first speaker today is
Kris Munroe we'll talk about quantum
computing with atoms go ahead Chris
okay thank you nación and David and the
other organized is the meeting you can
hear me okay yeah okay very good so I'm
going to spend some time talking about
several different experiments projects
I'll start at a pretty high level
talking about different technologies
generally and noticing you know some
very high-level considerations on on
these technologies in particular you'll
hear later this afternoon from Michel
Luca and about neutral atoms I'm going
to be talking about trapped ions of
course and when we think of experimental
components in quantum computing
what I've found over no the last few
decades is there's an interesting
culture and it's one that's based on the
the largely based upon the the amazing
success of VLSI silicon and so forth and
you know I started in this field more
building atomic clocks which is a little
bit far removed from even physics
sometimes but precision metrology trying
to isolate a quantum system TV extreme
individual atoms of course and one thing
that's
you know interesting to keep in mind in
chronic computing and this is a line
that Bill Phillips my colleague here
Marilyn likes to say he says that a
quantum computer differs more from a
laptop then that laptop differs from an
abacus and of course what he means here
is that the laptop and the abacus are
both at a very high level the same
Turing machine in an abstract way of
course one is very much more powerful
than the other but quantum computers are
completely different and to to me the
corollary as an experimentalist is that
why should we expect a quantum computer
to look anything like a classical
computer and so what when when you look
at the technologies out there you know
they're they're all exotic of course
because quantum computing demands
extreme isolation extreme isolation but
we also have to control things very
cleanly and that's very hard to do when
it's been isolated by design this is a
figure from science except for four
years ago it was the editors wrote a
review article on the field and they
listed a few different technologies and
I I had to add a few more to the end
they're neutral atoms and photonics
they're really coming on strong but I
would say of these of all these
technologies really the two on the Left
superconductors and trapped ions are
really the only ones so far that have
been built into systems that have been
built in such a way that the user
doesn't necessarily have to know what's
inside and that that's that that's not
really a physic statement but I think it
allows it allows us to look at quantum
computing from a higher level compilers
Gate sets native interactions versus the
ones in the textbook algorithm designers
love this because you know like your
smartphone who wants to know what's
inside you just want to use it and and
of course since 2016 there's been a
bunch of companies mostly in the u.s.
that have pushed forward vigorously on
the engineering of these systems mostly
superconducting loots again because they
can be built on chips and they're solid
state so they can leverage all the VLSI
and so forth that's behind you know
that's behind that information area in
the 20th century I put this slide
together this is since nobody could
throw tomatoes at me this is an
interesting slide that should be taken
with a big grain of salt this is over
the course of time the fidelity of
entangling operations on different on
three different technologies throughout
the years now the thing the reason why I
would dodge Tomatoes is that every one
of these points really only deals with
two qubits and only two qubits so when
you only have two qubits there is no
such thing as crosstalk for instance now
some of the points are getting beyond
that but what's interesting in these
technologies is that they're they're
getting they're all getting better or at
least they were until a few years ago
we'll see you can you can argue if you
want on these but these all come from
these are all data from from experiments
over the last twenty years or so and you
know they're all by the way corrected
for preparation and measurement error
spam hairs and so you know the the the
performance is a little bit worse than
this when you include spam errors you
might argue though that the marginal
cost in a quantum computation doesn't
really depend on spam at least the
lowest order unless you want to do error
correction so there's all kinds of
caveats here I just put this up here to
note that you know I started working
with Jeff nines over 20 years ago and
you know the data it looked great back
then but it's really horrible now and
you look at it and the rapid increase in
fidelity you know lowering of errors oh
the other the other thing that you won't
like here is I just the brute force
created fidelity from an error assuming
some type of a normal air propagation
anyways so again I don't want you to
take this home too much but things are
improving for sure now the atomic
systems the neutral atoms that have come
on strong recently we'll hear more about
that this afternoon and the ions are
quite different obviously than
superconductors and I'm going to try
over the course of the next few minutes
to highlight a little bit about that
one thing that's very interesting with
neutral atoms or trapped ions as opposed
to superconductors or solid-state
systems is that with atomic systems we
don't yet need error correction and
that's that may be a bold thing to say I
don't think it'll be true forever but
the native errors in atomic systems can
be so low that you'd be crazy to encode
things in an aircraft to qubit to start
with and I think you know gate depths in
excess of 10,000 is not unreasonable I
mean we know there are fundamental
errors but they're below that the other
thing I'll say is that the errors that
happen in atomic systems are not idle
errors we can engineer atomic systems or
pick the right systems so that there are
no t1 or t2 processes if you leave a
trap died alone its coherence is as long
as you need it it's an atomic clock so
it doesn't mean there are no errors is
just there are no idle errors no memory
errors the errors happen and they're
significant when you when you poke poke
laser beams and microwave fields into
them to get them to interact of course
they're gay errors so it's a different
way of looking at how errors propagate
and and the final thing I'll say at a
very high level is that and as much as I
hate to say this as a physicist there's
not a whole lot of physics left in
trapped ions this was really settled in
the last few decades we're not going to
learn about a better better kind of atom
you know maybe we can encode things in a
smarter way
maybe we can store four level systems
instead of two level systems but we're
not going to improve the atom itself
it's given to us so in fact the atomic
systems need a healthy dose of
engineering which is sort of turning the
tables from where I was thinking 20
years ago that solid state is more
engineering the atomic physics is
physics the atomic systems are physics
essentially the other way around I think
the solid state systems you know there's
beautiful ideas too on topological
qubits and even you know this curve
bringing superconductor t1 and t2 times
down sorry bringing their times up
making them more coherent it's based on
understanding the physics of the physics
of surfaces there is engineering
but I think there's much more physics
needed in solid-state an atomic system
so with atomic systems we can start
thinking about building systems at a
high level without worrying about the
technology underneath so this is a
picture of a ion trap okay we do use
solid-state technology but there's
nothing quantum of about the solid state
silicon chip here looks like a bowtie
it's got a bunch of gold electrodes on
it if you look closely you can see that
there's actually a junction it's sort of
like the Y Junction at either end these
ions there's a picture of a tee you
terbium ions and they're floating about
a tenth of a millimeter above this chip
this chip is about one centimeter wide
the inner poseur and it's about one
hitch wide see we can get both in purely
units and metric units in there so this
is a yes David oh just to throw in a
question I was thinking about your your
comment that there's no physics left in
ions and what about the measurement of
the time variation of the fine-structure
constant is that like I always thought
that is that's very fundamental is that
still going on of course it's not
quantum computing yeah you know I get a
lot of trouble especially as my amo
colleagues in atomic physics that when I
say no physics they they do throw
tomatoes I'm being a little bit you know
I'm being poking of course but indeed
there's all kinds of physics in
precision metrology my favorite is
measuring limits on the electric dipole
moment of the electron which is based on
the fact that when in a molecule the
electron samples a huge electric field
and you can see distortions in the
spectroscopy if there if it had a dipole
moment parity violation and as you said
if the if the lyman-alpha line and
hydrogen drifts over time
one reason is the fine-structure
constant changing over time so there's
you know this beautiful position for
ecology going on it's a culture and amo
that underlies everything I do
everything we do in quantum computing so
I yeah I get in a lot of trouble there
but I'm trying to you know start the pot
a little bit because I think there's a
huge opportunity especially in atomic
physics for us to look at a very high
level on quantum computing not just the
atomic systems but
things way upstairs okay hello in the
same vein isn't it also I mean all you
said that there is a chip but it's
boring but I thought it actually what's
the situation with anomalous heating you
know doesn't basically introduction of a
solid state surface bringing you back
the good old solid state physics has
that been installed stories that may be
also technical for most people but I
don't know okay
it's not quantum let me put it that way
that air in classical physics doesn't
have to be boring but indeed as Frank's
pointing out these atoms let me give you
a size of scale here I I was just gonna
get onto that these are 80 atoms and the
distance from left to right here is
about a half a millimeter so it's been
expanded quite a bit to see it the
spacing between these individual atoms
is about five microns they are a hundred
microns above the surface each atom is
laser cooled to and localized to a space
of a few nanometers as you know the
atoms themselves the electron wave
packets are a few tenths of you know a
tenth of a nanometer or something like
that or maybe even smaller than that
okay so the blobs you see here are
diffraction limited spots from our
optics now to get to your question what
is it really boring what's going on here
well the electrodes I look at the
electrodes they're about a hundred of
them on this chip you can't really see
it you can see the wires though that has
chip these electrodes are part of the
control system I would say they're part
of the control system and their
classical there's nothing quantum about
them these are the the electrode is at
room temperature
of course it's done in a vacuum chamber
so there's very little direct contact
with that thermal environment but as
Frank points out there's a long-standing
issue that there is surface noise that
we still don't quite understand we know
how to get rid of it but we don't want
to understand the physics the surface
physics
it could be adds more you know past
potentials or little contact grain
boundaries that are moving around they
tend they they tend to wiggle the ions a
little bit now the good news is and this
is where ions
differ from neutral atoms the good news
is ions are confined based on their
charge the qubit is inside the ion and
the charge we hold the ions without any
distortion of the qubit none whatsoever
with neutral atoms to hold on to them
you have to distort them with a dipole
force and in fact the qubit is stored in
a dipole effectively so it's very it
makes it harder to get rid of the
confinement systematics in neutral atom
qubits so the heating does affect the
motion of the ions but it doesn't affect
whatsoever the qubits there is a tiny
relativistic shift because if the ions
are wobbling around there is a frequency
shift to their levels but this is atomic
clock stuff at the 10 to the minus 19
level that we don't care about okay so
so this heating won't affect the qubits
but as I'll talk about in a minute it
will affect our ability to do gates
because the gates are going to involve
the motion of the atoms when we cool the
good news is here when we cool this chip
down to 4 Kelvin we don't need to go any
colder than 4 Kelvin and we don't need
to go to 4 Kelvin but 4 kelvins started
easy that's where helium liquefies and 4
Kelvin this problem largely goes away
it's sort of so it's we think it's
thermally driven and you can pretty much
freeze it out that said if the indeed is
there's most of the gates that we do
today
one more question which was typed in
from an attendee which is also on in a
sort of fundamental vein it's back to
the previous slide he says if you
suppose you actually want to push the
two qubit gate fidelity to to get a
world record where do you think it could
be brought down to if if the focus were
purely on getting the absolute best
fidelity oh yeah great question so there
all of these points with trapped ions
involve laser based optical laser based
gates and there's a fundamental error of
laser based gates we do Rayleigh
scattering really off of these atoms is
a dispersive but there's a tiny bit of
real scattering that pretty much
measures the cubit now the probability
of that happening in a given gait it
depends on the system is between ten to
the minus six and ten minus four so in
some systems will be encroaching on that
pretty soon 10 demise for now you know
we always have an answer but you know
the folks at NIST in Boulder and also in
Oxford and other places are are doing
research on using microwave field
gradients to drive gates and there you
don't have that problem of course you
have to put lots of microwaves on these
chips and it tends to make them glow
orange hot so you know there's other
issues there and I'm probably
exaggerating there but the fundamental
limit we see with laser-based gates and
that'll be true for the next you know 10
or 15 years is by me 10 demise 5 level
if we had to do that and of course it's
health that there's no crosstalk in any
of this data keep that in mind gonna
build a system none of these points
really matter anyway but they're more
about fundamentals ok great questions
yeah things are moving on and I'm gonna
have to skip some slides ok some atomic
physics sorry
there is physics right so we we
typically store qubits in two levels
within the atom one work one of the most
popular choices is to use ground state
hyperfine levels because these are the
same states that are used for atomic
clocks some of the best atomic clocks
microwave atomic clocks
there are also metastable like optically
defined levels that you can use as well
they're harder because you have to have
a coherent laser drive them whereas
microwaves are much easier to deal with
so in the ytterbium 171 ion you might be
surprised that the ytterbium ion has
such a simple structure it's because the
ytterbium plus has one outer electron
like hydrogen and the nucleus only has
spin 1/2 even though there's lots of
neutrons and protons there so it's a
very simple in terms of the quantum
numbers it's a very simple system
exactly that of hydrogen actually atomic
neutral hydrogen so these two levels
they're so-called clock states sometimes
because they have no same on shift to
first order so that's
you know the first step of isolation is
that we're not even sensitive to
magnetic fields these two other levels
here the 1 1 and 1 minus 1 they are
linearly sensitive to magnetic fields
but we don't use those for qubits so the
frequency of our cubed and ytterbium is
twelve point six gigahertz but of course
it's a clock so we can write down this
frequency to many more digits than I
have here so it's a very good qubit
right off right right from the get-go
room temperature system no shielding and
we can observe tens of seconds of
coherence if you really needed hours of
coherence we could do that too for true
we don't need that now we do use the
excited state to measure the qubit and
all the tommix systems have some type of
a scheme like this in this case by
sending light that's that's polarized
the right way only one state scatters
like crazy and the other state hardly
scatters at all it's because this is the
splitting here downstairs is much bigger
than the linewidth in the excited state
so there you know this is real data here
a single atom we either get a lot of
clicks on average or we get almost zero
clicks on average and the difference
between these two distributions can be
easily discriminated even in a single
shot so near perfect detection I think
the guys at Ginsberg have even put
another nine another nine and maybe a
nine five at the end of this on an
optical qubit so measurements really not
an issue with atomic systems now if you
get a million two bits you're going to
need a part per million detection there
are there are ways to do that but again
we're not going to worry about that
until we get there
the important interaction involves
making superpositions doing gates and
these are sort of the the knob from the
outside world without disturbing the
system and in fact this operation we use
laser based gates that are far detuned
from the excited state as I told you
before look at the numbers here the line
width of this excited state is 20
megahertz and we're detuned about a
million times that I get that right yeah
gigahertz tears right so 30 terahertz or
so and it turns out there's an optimum
place to put this laser so that there
are minimal stark shifts and other
systemic issues
and one I would say the main reason we
use you terbium is that the optimum
place to put the laser is a place where
we can get infinite power three five
five nanometers that's a tripled
neodymium YAG laser which is a standard
laser in the field this is one of them
this is the standard for etching CMOS
masks and doing photolithography it's
one of the finest engineered lasers out
there and as I like to say it only has
one adjustment and it's the on key you
turn it on and it runs for years without
thinking and so this is obviously a good
part of any system it's also a pulsed
laser meaning that it gives a frequency
column and I won't get into the details
but we can control the spacing of this
comb so that all comb teeth that have
twelve point six gigahertz between them
drive a coherent transition the time
scales are just right the pulses have a
bandwidth that covers this the ground
state splitting but they're also the
bandwidth is small compared to 33
terahertz so we don't scatter okay so
very briefly you've seen pictures of
this before but how we entangle qubits
trapped ion qubits it's actually fairly
simple when you look at it in this way
it has to do with the motion of course
the Coulomb collective motion of the
ions and this was first pointed out a
long time ago so our chair so I can and
his colleague Peter solar first showed
how to do this in a general sense since
then the the gate schemes have been
improved and I think most of us now use
something called the molar Sorensen gate
I call it an icing gate because it leads
to an icing coupling between spins
here's how it works imagine we are able
to shine lasers on any pair of these
ions what we're going to do is shine a
laser in a way that gives a spin
dependent force or state dependent force
and this is an optical tweezer the
dipole force that exactly is what is
used for trapping neutral atoms we'll
hear more about that this late evening
or afternoon here by Misha Lucan but
here were we're not using the laser to
confine the atoms we're using it to
modulate the confinement of the atoms so
this is a we can tune the puller
of this light in such a way that it's a
spin dependent force so if the atom is
in the state spin up it moves up if it's
in the state spin down it moves down and
the physically essential physics here is
that if you look just at these two ions
if they're both up there Coulomb
interaction just these two is exactly
the same it doesn't change staying with
if they're both down but if they're in
different states up-down or down-up
they're a little further apart and you
can calculate the defect and energy
under that influence and it looks like a
1 over R cubed it's a actually so
dipole-dipole interaction because we're
making dipoles we're making each atom
smear out in distance these are very big
dipoles much bigger than molecules so
the interaction is fairly strong but it
falls off like 1 over R cubed more on
that in a minute so if we just look at
these two ions they can be in any one of
these four states what happens is that
we we have a phase shift only if they're
in opposite states there are many
different ways of doing this isn't just
a simple one so if we set that phase to
be PI over 2 there's full entanglement
it's as expressive as a controlled-not
gate in it ok so this is basically the
moment Sorensen scheme now two things
that I swept under the rug the physics
here is essentially you're right if you
do it really fast I'll talk about that
in a second but first we actually do
this in the X basis not the Z basis as
I've written so so up and down X so a
plus down-up minus down that's the
natural basis for the Mon or Sorensen
gate so the evolution operator is an xx
gate Ising gauge as I mentioned these
gates are not as fast as what you see in
solid state they're typically 10s or
longer microseconds but again the
fidelities can be very high
now the other sleight of hand and what
you're worried about what makes this
problem hard is that all the other ions
are also moving around when you drive
motion with the spin dependent force
it's like plucking a guitar string I
mean there's all kinds of motion and the
gate is actually slow compared with all
the normal modes of vibration which are
typically megahertz so the oscillation
periods are fractions of a micro
the gate takes tens or hundreds of
microseconds so they're all they're all
involved only when you do this fast if
you have enough laser power to do this
much faster than a microsecond does this
physics work in that way otherwise you
have to treat all the normal modes of
motion it's sort of a mess but it's a
classical mess and that's a little bit
of the the moral of trapped I on quantum
computing yeah whenever there's a mess
it's a classical mess and we're kind of
comfortable dealing with that through
engineering and other other ways so
here's an example of what that means
though this is a spectrum we stokes
spectrum rahman sideband spectrum of
exactly 32 eyes in a chain and what this
carrier is that's the spin flip at
twelve point six gigahertz but when we
detune the laser beat note from the
carrier we drive emotional sidebands
because in the frame of the atom the
laser beam a running away laser beam
acquires FM sidebands they're not Bessel
functions because this is emotions
quantize it turns out that they're not
Bessel function side bands they're the
Legare polynomials but that's that's a
that's a detail enough to care about but
but here we have 64 features one and the
these are the radial nodes along X and
the radial is one y we're sensitive to
both of them we can turn off either
dimension if we want but we wanted to
see all of them here and we can identify
every one of these lines this is like
molecular spectroscopy except we know
exactly where we're not learning any
physics here this is all classical
normal mode analysis so but it is a mess
we're driving mode normal modes of all
these sixty-four modes in general now
there is some good news here it might
not be obvious but by driving normal
modes we no longer have a dipole
interaction it's all - all
they're all roughly equally strong
normal modes are delocalized the
center-of-mass mode right the center of
mass one has no sense of distance even
the this strength did the tilting mode
like this that we can see my hands the
tilting mode has an inverse sense of
distance the ones that are farthest
apart have the strongest coupling okay
so when you sum over all those normal
modes you get some interesting ways to
make gates but you have to so the good
news is you have all the all
connectivity with those no sacrifice and
speed the bad news is you have to do a
lot of classical control of the laser
beam to deal with those modes and we do
that I am probably not gonna have to I
won't have any time to really talk about
how we do that we do laser pulse shaping
so that all these modes are excited and
at the end of the gate they all return
to where they started it's a classical
computation it relies on these modes
being being drifting around but we can
design pulses that even consider that so
there's lots of opportunity for
classical control here we take that to
do lots of classical control now one
last comment I'll say is that we've
learned that when you get more than
about 30 ions there's a degree of
locality to these in other words if in
principle I had a thousand ions in a
chain and we're hitting number 50 it
turns out we're probably not going to
easily do a gate between 50 and 500 it's
going to be we're going to have local
we're gonna have binary reactions plus
or minus 20 the way something like that
but the good news is as we add more eyes
we don't have to pull shape anymore we
don't have to worry about all the others
so it's like plucking a guitar string in
two places and yet they should sort of
cancel really far away so yeah and
that's it's all classical physics though
okay let's talk about the system here we
go
32 is an important number because we
have a device a 32 channel switch
optical switch we can do anything we
want to these 32 beams to drive any gate
we want we can frequency modulate phase
modulation amplitude modulation to do
everything we want we can do gates in
parallel we can put them all on at the
same time in this system I don't want to
say it's you know it's not like it's not
like a smart phone yet but when it works
it works for
any hours at a time without touching and
a few years ago we've noticed that in
the morning after optimizing the system
we were able to run small quantum
circuits from a very high level and as I
said before we can start thinking about
this quantum computer stack involving
compiling gates all the way down to the
hardware I talked about and just pulse
shaping in the middle we have to do that
on the fly if things drift we have to
recalculate all those laser pulses so
all kinds of classical engineering and
control here so with that you know I
obviously can't go through many of these
we sort of you know the systems not on
the cloud but but it it's it
sufficiently attentive free that we have
had all kinds of collaborations with
folks largely in condensed matter
running certain models certain circuits
and it's been a lot of fun over the last
few years I don't want to say again like
I said like I said we're not doing
atomic physics anymore we're doing
things like you know one of my one of my
favorite examples is this just this
litmus test for quantum scrambling I'd
involve only seven cubits so you know
lower your science but you know that
quantum scrambling is this idea that you
have you have a depth of entanglement
that's as big as the system itself and
it has a lot to do with black holes and
and some theories on how information
the fate of information in a black hole
and and in this case we quickly go
through this with a collaboration with
Norman Yahoo and Berkeley and Bennie Oh
sheet at perimeter they proposed the
idea of a three qubit scrambling litmus
test
so three qubits so here's a circuit and
the question is does this unitary
scramble or not you and I won't go into
details of the circuit just to note that
we have to apply U and u dagger and this
simple version is a post selective
circuit depending on the bell
measurement of certain pairs of qubits
it'll turn out that u scrambles if and
only if this state gets teleported over
there
based on previous entanglement this is
you know pairwise EPR entanglement and
these Bell state measurements and of
course it's only three qubits so it's
not exactly a black hole
we have to apply the inverse as well so
this is closely related to these out of
time ordered correlator measurements
that you see in other context and we're
going to here with a circuit and of
course if we have some circuit like like
this one here I want to get into details
but it has a bunch of entangling gates
these icing gates three qubits and
there's a parameter theta if theta is
zero there's no scrambling and if theta
is PI over 2
there's maximal scrambling and again I
won't prove that but that's just the
example test 3 cubed circuit and here's
the raw data the teleportation fidelity
going above 1/2 means that there's some
scrambling in you and I'll note also
that even if u and u dagger aren't
perfect inverses or these EPR pairs
aren't perfect what that amounts to is a
rate of success in the bell measurement
going down not the fidelity of the
teleportation there's an extension to
this circuit that where we apply sort of
a grover type search on the outputs here
that makes it deterministic and not Poe
selective and boy I can see I'm really
ringing out of time we you know these
these EPR States at the beginning you
can think of them as infinite
temperature thermo field double states
that means anything to you but we've
started extended this in a collaboration
with Tim Tim say perimeter to make a
so-called thermal field double state
under a particular Hamiltonian I'll talk
about that in a minute but this is sort
of a two mode squeezed state here
between qubits that are subject to some
Hamiltonian and it's a pure state but it
has a fake temperature in there so that
when you trace over one of the two
systems a or B the other system is in a
thermal state with temperature T beta is
1 over KT here and we this is a little
bit of a change but there's very much
interest in putting not EPR pairs but
finite temperature thermo field double
States into this circuit
which sort of models some you know
thermodynamics of information going in
black holes and yet I'm on thin ice in
that in that direction but again that's
the kind of physics I'm starting to
learn so like being in school again so
the thermo field double stay here we
built a very small one based on six
cubed
and it was made using a QA way type
operation where we have layers of
operations z rotations x XX gates and we
divide the system into 3 plus 3 so the
thermo field got a holy has three cubits
he only has three cubits so pretty small
and again Tim has thought a lot about
with with only a couple of layers well
actually you can get a perfect replica
of the TFD state within over two layers
and that's without any transverse field
in this in this hamiltonian so again I
apologize I'm going super fast here and
the data behind this once you think
you've generated it to this state's very
hard to make we don't really know how to
make prescribe a TFD state based on
gates so we use this cue AOA upper type
routine with classical optimization in
this case we can use analytic formulas
to decide based on the this transverse q
licensing model between all six pins
what's going on and again I think I
could spend 20 minutes on this slide the
measurements at the end of the day
between the two subsystems and within
the subsystem sort of agree with theory
as a function of this fake temperature
here down on the bottom and temperature
here is measured in terms of well you
can see my units are bad i I said not
only H bar equal to 1 but the the
overall the overall field and the
overall Ising coupling equal to each
other n equal to 1 so the temperature is
in those units and clearly the action
happens when temperature goes above a
few units here and again you can consult
this paper on the art guide if you're
interested but we'd obviously like to
make bigger ones well we'd like to do
everything bigger of course and back to
the system engineering issue this is
really the problem even though we have a
couple of ions in here and they weren't
great you can see that the
infrastructure needed mostly optical you
know all these optical amounts have
they're all they're all you know they're
ball bearings on them and three screws
they're all flexible and in fact I would
say they're probably too flexible
because this is a physics lab where we
can we can adjust the experiment to do
all kinds of different things we've
recently like in anything if you know
you want to do you can freeze the design
make it smaller and therefore it will
perform better and we've spent a lot of
the last few years and one of our
projects doing exactly that
and without much exaggeration that last
picture everything in there everything
on the optical table here all that stuff
is sort of crammed into this meter cubed
box including the laser so all of the
gate lasers and so forth and optical
switches they're all in there the vacuum
chamber the chip and the atoms and and
this this project is an odd project for
a university it's funded by a ARPA at a
pretty high level because we needed to
make a system we need to work with
Sandia on designing their chip for us we
need to work with a bunch of companies
to to take their like Harris makes this
32 channel optical switch for
lithography actually is for some oddball
app on the VLSI floor at the factory and
we told them you know you actually made
that for us we want you to re-engineer
it for us because it has everything we
want and so we work very closely with
the optical engineers down there and
we're basically integrating these parts
into our chamber coherent makes the 355
laser I talked about cold quanta makes
very small vacuum chambers AO sense
makes miniature CW lasers ok so again i
feel like i'm not going to give this as
much covers i was like the i ARPA
program is actually about error
correction and I'm gonna I'm gonna feel
like a hypocrite a little bit here we're
at we are doing experiments with error
correction but to me error correction is
a little bit of a way to benchmark your
quantum computer you can encode and
measure and all those things you need to
do anyway in any quantum computation so
it sort of makes sense this the goals
through IR are perfectly in line with
what we want to do anyway we're going to
do more than just zero correction but
we've we've been playing around a lot
with a 13 qubit air crafting code a
bacon Shore 911 3 code where the data is
encoded in 9 cubed and four cubits in
the middle represented by this sort of
plot ket can you know you can you can
develop stabilizers of subsets of the
nine cubits and map them onto these four
and
measure them and it's more we're using
it more as an air detection code right
now we're not we're not we're not yet if
it'll to to feedback measure a subset of
the qubits without affecting all the
others not yet because all these atoms
have the same they're the same species
if we measure any one of them they all
sort of go but we've been sort of
flexing flexing the system here by
measuring these these four wait six
stabilizers sort of represented by these
rectangles the blue and gold rectangles
in the X and Z basis and we've even done
some detection of the airs and and run
logical single qubit rotations on the
logical qubits so you know it's a little
little highlights here this is an
encoding step it's it's a simple
encoding it's sort of separable three
qubits three qubits and three cubits but
of course we have to run a bunch of
these are these are basically mullmer
sorenson or Ising gates between all nine
data qubits and these ants Ella's these
foreign Cilla's that hold the stabilizer
values so these circuits are fairly deep
in the system and oh by I didn't mention
we actually used fifteen cubits instead
of thirteen because the last two they're
actually a little further apart than the
middle ones I didn't say we make the
ions pretty much equally spaced but the
last two are little further out so we
don't use them we think of them as end
caps they're part of the trap if you
want so there's sort of dummy ions 15
but it's a fairly deep circuit requiring
many dozens of gates and so forth and so
you know the data on encoding and and
since we can map onto the stabilizers
and measure them we can we can in a post
selective way throw away know that we
have an error and not deal with that
data and you know the fact that those
error rates after detection you know
this is a post selected area to solo
sort of verifies that our errors are not
there there are the good type they're
not non-local errors that are not
correctable by this distance three code
and finally again this is a deep
collaboration with John st. Kim and Ken
Brown and Duke especially Ken and this
is an example of doing single qubit
operations
on these on these cubits I've put this
data up here because this data is only a
few weeks old we've been running that
system non-stop for the last six weeks
and the data is actually better than
it's ever have been and better than it
ever has been because the building is a
ghost town
there's no vibrations and the
temperature is very stable and because
we engineered the system to to run in
this box we can run it from home we have
to go in about every week and you know
turn on a computer that froze and shut
off but we don't open that box or do any
any optics or atomic physics okay
I'm going to go down the street to inq
briefly as you know Jung sang Kim and I
co-founded a company it's in College
Park about a mile away from the lab at
Maryland called inq they build ion trap
quantum computing systems they have
about 60 employees and right now they're
11 they're working at any one time we're
sort of I'm not sure how we argued it
worse we're essential but I guess they
make plenty of loopholes so that if you
are really careful about distancing and
all that you can keep going so we're not
building a new assistant but we're
running existing systems and other the
four systems we've built actually system
one has been retired we're working on
four now these two are our course and
they are one or the other are going to
be put on the Microsoft Azure cloud and
the other on the Amazon bracket cloud
AWS cloud fairly soon and to give you an
idea of the high level of engineering
there this is a real-time picture of
loading exactly 24 qubits and they're
actually loaded on the side of this chip
trap and one-by-one shuttled into the
middle zone here and and merged with the
existing chain you can even see their
zigzagged
as we load just for how come I'm loading
and once we get all 24 the camera knows
it we stretch them out and then refocus
all automatically done now ready to go
for a long nice long time you know our
hours this is a room-temperature system
when we go to 4 Kelvin a chain like this
will last for months without without
unless somebody shuts off the power
so lots of lots of autonomous and very
high-level engineering involved with
this software controls are pretty
exquisite way beyond what I could ever
think of doing an IQ they've run they've
been playing a lot with benchmarking
textbook algorithms like the Bernstein
Bowser Ronnie of course this is in a
sense it's not as interesting as other
algorithms because it missing the right
word it involves gates that can be
simulated classically of course it's an
Oracle type algorithm but it's a nice
test of our system it allows us to this
is a this is a circuit with 20 cubits 19
data and one and Scylla so two to the
19th is half a million and so they're
half a million Oracles we could program
we did I don't know several thousand of
them and it allows you to test the
fidelity of all these gates we can also
make the you'll notice the connectivity
required here is interesting the ancilla
needs to be connected to everybody but
we can we can change the assignment that
and so low so we can have any
conductivity we want it's a nice way to
sort of test out the system and the
great the great thing about purchasing
maserati is every time you run the
circuit there's only one answer and you
have a work or not so you run it a few
hundred times you get the probabilities
and with this nineteen bv 19 circuit the
probabilities are something like 80
percent or something averaged over all
the and all the Oracles that we did
another benchmark we're working on is
the vqe algorithm in molecular
simulation we've been working on the
water molecule I don't have time to talk
about that this paper will tell you a
little bit about that we've only made
the first few steps in the convergence
to the ground state of water which
interestingly I think what we learned
here was almost theoretical that the
brute force vqe on earth are required to
get to chemical accuracy required like
12 qubits and 702 qubit gates we
compiled it down partly because the the
Ising gate it has lots of lots of small
very small rotations surrounded by C not
gay
those are expensive we can replace that
with a small rotation Ising gate so the
icing gate has a continuous parameter
it's very expressive and it's perfect
for vqe so we can press those 700 opps
down to 100 150 so we should be able to
get all the way to chemical actually in
water with just 12 qubits on our devices
and of course the full connectivity in
this you know we're working with both a
campus and at IQ with about 21 qubits
right now full conductivity is there and
you know again it's a big speed-up in
terms of running a generic algorithm I
want to for the remaining time I want to
switch gears a little bit on the physics
side not atomic physics image but more
simulation of magnetism condensed matter
models by turning on all of the means at
the same time we don't have gates
anymore between between qubits we have
serve an OLE on all IC interaction and
instead of closing all these face spaces
we we operate in the dispersive regime
which means that these spin dependent
forces to actually don't they don't move
the eyes very much but they're on for
longer we wait longer and it's a sort of
an index of refraction if you want it's
a dispersive interaction and we can
realize this long range Ising model
where the icing coupling falls off with
a power law that's pretty you know the
power is very long range alpha here the
distant the distance I minus J between
these ions this power law goes between
zero and three the sweet spot is around
one so it's a it's a very long range
interaction and we've made many
simulations in this direction and again
I'm going to skip over you know the this
one pre thermalization I want to talk a
little bit about aq AOA optimization of
the ground state of this Ising model not
by going to a Trotter type you know
infinite series of H a and H B for
infinitesimal times but for relatively
long times we can apply layers of H a
and H B that don't commute and and
perhaps optimize the system to find the
ground state so we can measure the
energy after applying H a then H B then
AJ then H B we can measure the
and see how see how well it performed
and each layer of applying hhb has a
classical parameter basically it's time
how long did you apply the icing
coupling how long do you apply the
transverse field and according to the
the standard prescription of cue AOA you
can use a classical optimizer just to
see how well you did gradient descent
and so forth and again but very briefly
our figure of Merit is sort of the
energy and we get minus the maximum
energy divided by the ground state minus
next so when 8 is equal to 1 that's good
that means you hit the ground state and
and and as you can see over over many
iterations over these are only one and
two layers but over many iterations we
can we can guess better values for these
parameters these betas and these gammas
to get close now the dotted line is
theory in theory how close we expect we
could get after two sorry two layers
it's not exactly 1 and you know how you
scale this is is tricky this is a little
bit of an artificial figure of Merit
because it involves the entire bandar
through the energy levels but you can
sort of see that in theory the the
system does march towards somewhat close
to its optimal value so it's a it's a
QAM a type operation and we've done this
on up to 40 spins and again by
increasing the number of spins we don't
have to worry about individual lasers
the engineering is not so bad and lastly
this is this is a couple of years ago
with over 50 spins we measured
properties of a so called dynamical
faith transition where again our
transverse Ising model here there's a
competition between procession around Z
field and order along the X direction
when we measure the magnetization of
these spins it's sort of a boring
observable it doesn't really undergo a
phase transition it's small relatively
small fields when they're prepared along
the x-direction nothing much happens
because they're already paired there in
a pair long X at very high fields they
end up
to measure magnetization along next they
process around Z and we see this
dynamics definitely different type of
dynamics but this is a very smooth
transition if we measure correlators we
see at a certain this is different
numbers of spins now we see at certain
values of B every day we you see what it
looks like
could be a dip this dash line is mean
field theory which of course doesn't
work very well at large B every day we
sort of see a dip but it was
disappointing when we went from sixteen
to fifty three spins the dip didn't get
very sharp we expect a logarithmic
divergence for the in the infinite spin
limit we didn't see that at all but by
looking at I mean we can measure all
possible correlators every shot with
very high fidelity so we looked at in
this case a weird parameter basically
the size of the largest domain wall so
so the largest domain and average that
over over many runs and as we change B
over J we see that it hits a minimum and
it's much sharper and this is an example
of a simulation where we actually
couldn't compute that kink where what's
the magic guy he would be over J where
this happens it's not exactly a 1 you
don't expect it it's some funny value
around 0.9 okay so maybe it's not
quantum supreme I can't prove that
somebody can compute this but it's
something that we you know we certainly
couldn't do and you know we couldn't get
anywhere with class with computing on
this one
now it's also not necessarily an
interesting physical problem it's a
long-range Ising model but it's probably
more physical than random circuits above
that all right see I can't see
everybody's face it's really hard if
people are really frowning or laughing
or throwing things so I wanna I want to
sort of close by noting that you know
I've said all along that the ion systems
are interesting because the challenges
are in a totally different direction
that it's more about the controls from
the electrodes to the lasers and making
things small and and miniaturized and
high-performing we also know that there
are technologies that we're going to add
that we haven't really done it yet that
spend more in the Physics Laboratory
that will allow us to scale it will lost
the scale indefinitely and the reason
I'm confident in that is then these are
atomic clocks you can
million of them they're exactly the same
we don't worry about any homogeneity s
and the Cubans but the control issue is
an issue we have to be able to deal with
all these and we're looking toward a
type of a modular type of scaling where
we can maybe deal with 32 here 32 there
32 there and then wire them at distance
we actually know how to do that with
photons photonics and it's been done
with very small numbers of numbers of
atoms but the idea is if we can have
these individual modules and each of
them a subset of qubits can be mapped
onto photons we can Herald entanglement
across modules and this is a very
large-scale architecture you can think
about scaling to huge truly huge numbers
and I think really it involves more
engineering than physics here and the
bait the basics of this photonic
interaction is well known it's a hunger
Mandal type of double heralding
experiment that's been reproduced in
many different technologies even with RF
photons and super microwave photons and
superconductors and the idea is you
repeat until it works so you sacrifice
these two ions until they work and then
you get a belt pair and then you can
distribute the entanglement using gate
teleportation and the good news is that
when we started this about 10 years ago
the rate of doing this successfully was
really bad it was 10 to the minus 3
Hertz so you had to wait 10 minutes
before the single-click got you there
and the good news is Dave Lucas's group
at Oxford has you know we've been
improving we got above a few Hertz
couple years ago and their group is
approaching a few hundred Hertz and the
limitation is really in this experiment
or light collection is really
engineering just light collection and
and getting very clean fibers where we
can couple very well good detectors I
think we can get these numbers up to
many kilohertz without without changing
any of the physics here now when we get
to many kilohertz it's becoming
competitive with the molar Sorenson
gates we already use so that's really
interesting because then it makes this
architecture this architecture here not
not so ridiculous if the photonic
interactions are as fast as the local
ones
you should use them more and more and
maybe we turn to these photonic chips
that you know that people are making
like like like Xanadu and inside quantum
maybe we would love to use their
technologies for these ions in the long
run so with that this is my last slide
that I borrowed from Hartmut Neven added
my own points here this is sort of a
trapped ion work some of these data
points with lots of qubits are not full
control these are simulators this is
from NIST the penning trap experiment
with a few hundred ions and doing
expensive easy experiments here's
exactly two qubits with you know they
showed early on with 10 to the minus 3
hairs you know neither these is so
useful you really want to be up and to
the right and we're working there and I
it's easy to project in red here what's
gonna happen in the future we it's
probably going to be interesting but I
don't see any I don't see any
fundamental problem in getting getting a
few hundred qubits with few 10,000
operations without any error correction
of course eventually we need error
correction if you want to hit something
like this point way up there so with
that this is a picture of my group we're
just inside the beltway outside of
Washington DC and also the picture of a
group the early picture of the group at
high and cute just down the road and
that's all I have thank you
[Music]